yeah it's Friday be excited for fun
times and free games because this
episode's got something old something
new something borrowed and something
blue and you don't even have to make a
huge life mistake to get a bunch of free
gifts it's already right here for the
taking let's start off with the grab bag
of free classics from blizzard you've
already got a battle.net account for
warcraft Diablo and starcraft but now
you can put it to good use by
downloading lost vikings rock and roll
racing in blackthorn actually you don't
even need a battlenet account you'd like
download it like right here click on
just click on like the PC link and just
take it rock and roll racing is a
classic game that many gamers are in
love with but this is just the demo
version so it's not everything you once
loved the Lost Vikings and blackthorn
are single player 2d platformers but
you're really going to love controlling
the three Vikings each with their own
unique powers using all three together
will help you complete stage and this
game is not a walk in the park you'll
really have to use your brains to get
these Vikings to escape an alien Emperor
who wanted to use the three bearded
heroes as exhibits in a zoo can't make
that [ __ ] up next up get in on the open
beta action with wildstar now I know
what many of you are thinking oh this
world really needs another MMO well it
does just shut I'll break it down for
you get quest we got dungeons you get
player versus player combat be sure and
try out the healer which is loads of
funny because you can't just stand back
and cast you got to get in on the action
with a range cone style feel that saves
a day while you dodge duck dip dive and
dodge the open beta starts this weekend
which lets you play up to a level 30
until it goes live may 18 now let's take
a trip to the DC Universe with injustice
gods among us roll it out 3 vs 3 style
serving out punches or in Catwoman's
case high kick to increase your combo
meter once full you can really increase
your damage with a few well-placed swipe
from the right direction to give an
ultra
sure maybe blast your opponent with a
barrage of bullets or just squash them
like the butts they are fighting is
addictive but your heroes will most
likely run out of energy and you'll be
encouraged to strengthen your comic
characters the only way you know how
with Indian currency Green Lantern loves
those benjamins but you don't have to
spend any of your own green to get a
kick out of this solid fighter and
finally let's take a look at the game
that gives you the godly powers you
always deserve the smite this is a MOBA
but a more action-oriented one that has
you controlling your God using wast
controls because God's don't click where
they want to go they just go wherever
they want to go the latest patch
introduces siege mode a new god Osiris
new league ranking system skins and a
barrage of bug fixes oh my this game is
fun and action-oriented and GameSpot is
hooking you up with codes that will
unlock the powerful Odin as well as his
alternate skin the Huntsman why do you
think we call it free games Friday
because when you go to gamespot com /
might give away you get free stuff go
yes that's it for this episode stop
watching go download some games and
enjoy your weekend see ya
hey